great too happy where it's great the
beers
um hope you it's fantastic to have you
on the show you are you you are very
famous in Sweden especially and okay we
don't need to talk about that but but I
think I think first of all being I this
this choice of being the goalkeeper it
is a bit some some people feel that
that's like being the drummer in the
band that it's not so it's a bit
thankless to be the goalkeeper but you
love it I do love it but I would never
allow my child to play I don't wish it
on anybody it is a very thankless
position it's it's um you're never good
enough you know I mean the object of the
game is to score goals and so you feel
like you're feeling all the time but I
mean it's a very thankless position but
I do love it because it's challenging
and you can net it's something that you
can never perfect you you what's a very
good description you we got to talk
about Rio and what happened in Rio
because you us lost to Sweden in the
quarterfinals and and and you call the
Swedish team cowards you want to
elaborate on that yeah of course well
first off I truly do apologize for Karl
Allegiant so I don't
so if anybody actually listened to the
interview and I'm not sure if you have
but it was a very I wasn't enraged
I wasn't emotional I wasn't angry I just
had this conversation with all of the
journalists in the room after the game
and we were talking about the style of
play we weren't talking about you know I
didn't mean to come across that the
players were cowards or the coach was a
coward
I meant the style of play was not it
wasn't very Olympic spirit tuned um you
know I think lota helene number 8 the
captain for sweden of course is one of
the best players in the world one of the
best attacking players in the world so
it was really difficult to watch her
drop back defensively and I saw her most
of the time in the 18-yard box in her
defense and I wanted her to attack me I
wanted to play against Lotte I wanted to
try to stop her shots I loved the
competitive nature between America and
Sweden and I just you know it was a
little disappointing to see them drop
back to the 50-yard line to play defense
but I also said in the interview that
you know my hat goes off to them because
we're going home and they're going on to
Rio did you talk to Lata oh yeah so I I
played in Sweden in my when I was 22
years old
I live yes I lived in Gothenburg um so I
have a wonderful relationship with lota
and a very mutually respect you know we
mutually respect one another and I spoke
to her after the game and I said to her
you know lota I said something I use the
word cowards
you know when talking about you guys and
I didn't mean that I'm so sorry and she
she was like oh I know you don't worry
about it don't don't worry about it and
she's like look the American team has
been in the last five championship games
in the Olympics five championships and
she's like we never have she's like so
for us to be a better skilled team like
Brazil and like America we had to drop
back defensively and she knew it
but for the most part we just hugged and
we laughed and she accepted my apology
she didn't even think I needed to
apologize and we caught up about each
other's family and how she just moved
back to Sweden for to was living in in
France for so long and and it was just a
beautiful relationship that I have with
lota and so when I got back to America
and America was saying I have to
apologize I was able to look at myself
in the mirror because I spoke to lota
and there were no hard feelings
did you speak to PL sundog of the coach
as well you know her very well
I dunno if you very well she was our
coach for quite some time I have won an
Olympic gold medal with Pia yeah um but
no I didn't have a chance to to speak to
her um no she coaches the other teams so
it's kind of hard to speak to peer or
have a relationship with you anymore
what happened was that that this led to
to your contract with American soccer
being canceled and it was a very
dramatic thing in your life and a very
strong reaction I'm sure most people
agree and if it's okay by you I want to
show a clip where you get to know this
is it okay it is okay but I have to say
something real quick before everybody
sees the clip please understand that
this was a very real moment in my life
yeah this is my first firing yeah I
dedicated my life to the US team and I
had been on the team for over 17 years
and I was shocked I was devastated when
I found out the news and so what you're
going to see is very raw um so yeah okay
and there was a camera there so
terminated contract is immediately
terminated contracts not just suspended
I don't have after the new year that's
how up how do you feel today
how is uh I mean now there's been some
time and uh I are you in the same place
or is it um I don't really know where
I'm going with my life right now
so if anybody I thought got me a job
please I'm jobless I thought you were
quite measured out guys I I would expect
you to throw that water picture across
the room and go crazy because this was a
very emotional moment for you and I was
watching you watch yourself and it was
almost like you're reliving it that's
what I was saying yeah I mean it's still
very very painful yeah but to be honest
these last 30-plus days I've had the
opportunity to be home and not travel as
much and to enjoy my family and my dogs
and my husband and every day we wake up
my husband and I who's retired he
playing the NFL for ten years and so
he's retired at 36 and we wake up and
he's like well what do you want to do
today he goes people don't understand
that the best part about retirement is
you can wake up every single morning and
actually decide what you want to do
without obligations and then he looked
at me one time I'm not retired and I'm
not retiring just just to be clear but
he looked at me and he goes retirement
suits you I'm gonna display everything
going on and it's been very difficult
yeah I've been really happy at home I've
been really happy just figuring out the
next stage in my life of course it's
scary but I have a great support system
in place and who knows who knows what
will happen I've had a lot of offers to
play overseas so maybe Sweden will
welcome me back that would be
I am utterly confused by this I'm
utterly confused by the termination for
you just saying that there are people in
American sports men that have said and
done the most crazy violent things and
they get a slap on the wrist and they
get suspended for a bit and then you see
them right back doing everything playing
like crazy and having endorsers coming
back sneakers liquid energy and you just
said that and then you I'm very I'm
stupefied confused right now
honestly I get it there are more layers
to it that I don't think everybody quite
understands um I believe the Federation
used my comment saying the word cower
and to terminate me um it was about more
than well the outcome and I've been
fighting for I'm sure you guys have all
heard that I've been fighting for equal
pay and I've been the lead voice behind
the push for equal pay and in fact in
all the court documents that says Hope
Solo versus United States lager
hydration our CBA is about to expire on
December 31st and we're fighting for a
new contract moving forward with
retirement for health reimbursement
funds better treatment all across the
board and in the United States it's
actually federal law to pay your
employees equally based off of gender so
not only do we bring in more money for
the Federation than the men's team yeah
but it's federal law it's the Equal Pay
yet you have the same employer doing the
same job putting in the same amount of
time granted we're more successful at it
than our men's team
for the conduct in that case it almost
makes it worse
this is a fight worth fighting for and
I'm going to be on the right side of
history at the end of all of this
because I'm thinking of the history
books and you're all over them and it
really takes people like me and it sucks
with me just sitting here as a woman and
me fighting for my world which is like
you know equal pay and equal
representation for women of color in the
fashion industry that was my kind of
thing went back in the day when as a
model and to this day just really trying
to expand the definition of beauty and
people not wanting to hire me because I
was so outspoken about that so
unfortunately you are the person that
art that is getting this knife you know
through you but at the same time it's
going to open up so much and you are
that Martin Luther King
you always been before you've been proud
of that side of you that you always
speak your mind that's that's that's
something you're usually proud of do you
sometimes wish that you weren't that
kind of person well I'm not a loose
cannon like I think the media something
says yeah a lot of people think that um
I believe in authenticity I believe in
honest interviews and I think it's um
one of my best characteristics and
qualities and I think it also is one of
my worst because many people who
interview me say you know gosh and
athlete is is such a breath of fresh air
and athlete who actually isn't giving
the PC answers that they've heard time
and time again and they really enjoy
interviewing me and then other times you
know it's it just I end up terminated I
end up fired I end up being outspoken
which I used to think was a derogatory
term but I'm very proud of being
outspoken because I think that you can't
make change in the world unless you
speak up unless you are outspoken so all
the media out there who calls me
outspoken to try and put me down I am
very proud of you
where did you get that that personality
where did you get that from is it from
your mama your dad um I'm not really
sure my father was very stubborn very
stubborn man he always said I got I got
that from him um my mother strong woman
she was like a black belt in karate and
um she ski and she was semi-professional
skier um she was just very strong in
herself and and then of course there was
my grandmother so I don't know I think
we're all just you know you've heard of
our environment your father he was in
prison for parts of your childhood
um um well my father came back from
Vietnam and you know he was trying to
get his life together and I loved him
very much
and never had any hard feelings for him
even though he was kind of in and out in
and out um because I I knew he had a
great heart and I knew he was trying but
he just wasn't really able to figure out
his place in the world
um and I learned a lot from it I I
learned the beauty to love and to
forgive and most of all for my father I
learned to appreciate the simple things
in life because my father lived on the
streets when he came back from Vietnam
and he lived in downtown Seattle and he
was homeless and some of my best
memories with him were making macaroni
and cheese and taking it down to the
water and sitting with him and just
eating mac and cheese down by the water
in Seattle and we had some of the most
beautiful conversations and I've learned
so much for my father so yeah I mean he
went through his own struggles in life
as we all do um but I did learn so much
from him as well
so you're not quitting
but still you are you're now sort of
checking out how life without soccer is
can you imagine another career like
modeling like no mom is not our life for
me listen looking at you look we all
want you we're like bidding for you I am
keeping my hope I must agree with the
people that you said enjoy interviewing
you it's a great it's a great experience
to interview and thank you so much for
being thank you